foreign
european union is an important partner
at the for japan
to together address
the common challenges facing the
international community
japan eu relations
are getting closer than ever
based upon the economic partnership
agreement and strategic partnership
agreement which i have negotiated myself
when i was a foreign minister
at our summit had today we were able to
confirm
in realizing the free and open in the
pacific as well as japan eu green
alliance and also japan eu connectivity
partnership based upon all hote's
endeavors that we will further promote
our cooperation in various areas
including the climate change
as well as to strengthen cooperation in
economic security as well as energy
sectors
i am delighted that we have agreed to
launch the digital partnership which is
a comprehensive cooperative framework in
the digital sector between japan and
european union
data free flow with the trust trust
the fft will be further promoted through
this partnership i also welcome
and delighted that we came to agreement
in in having
uh the air services horizontal hood
agreement we have come to substantial
agreement on her disagreement
russia's aggression against ukraine
shakes the very foundation of the entire
international order
not just for europe but for asia as well
and can never be
condoned japan is collaborating with g7
including the european union
to
implement a powerful sanction
vis-a-vis russia and we have been
strengthening our assistance to ukraine
japan and eu will be working her closely
based upon her the perspective of the
global food security
and we have agreed
to make appeals to the countries in asia
and africa
in the working lunch her too had to
follow
in view
to the
indivisibility
of security for europe and security for
in the pacific
we will be discussing how to respond to
the
attempts to unilaterally change the
status quo by force as well as
economic coercion
and also how to respond her to north
korea including the missile development
and the abduction issue and also her to
discuss east asian situation iranian
situation disarmament as well as
non-proliferation
president michel will be visiting
hiroshima
tomorrow i welcome her that he will be
visiting peace memorial museum and offer
a wreath
i hope that we can work closely with the
european union
to move to our grand grand ideals of
world free of nuclear weapons
as a result of our consultation that we
are able to send a joint statement we
hope had to put forward a positive and
powerful message
from japan and eu
thank you may i now invite the president
michelle
thank you
dear prime minister dear fumio
it's a pleasure to meet you and your
team for our 28th
japan eu summit thank you for your warm
welcome to tokyo
today we discussed the deepening
strategic and economic partnership
between the european union and japan
we addressed our bilateral relations and
important regional and global challenges
and how best to coordinate our responses
the eu and japan are truly like-minded
partners
together we represent a quarter of
global gdp we have a deep and dynamic
relationship united by the fundamental
values of democracy and rule of law
japan is our closest strategic partner
in the indo-pacific region
and russia's war against ukraine has
shown that deeper cooperation is not a
luxury it's a vital necessity
today's summit is an opportunity to
build on this momentum
and to maximize the full potential of
our partnership across the right range
of issues
and this summit takes place as russia
continues to savagely attack the people
of ukraine
we responded in close coordination to
condemn russia and to impose punishing
sanctions
i'd like to thank you dear prime
minister in japan for your solidarity
together we are providing significant
humanitarian
financial and military support to
ukraine and its people
we also discussed our cooperation to
prevent the circumvention of sanctions
and to combat this
and we are convinced those responsible
for war crimes
must be and will be brought to justice
we also discussed the global impact of
the war on energy and food security
our cooperation in ukraine is critical
in europe but it's also important in the
indo-pacific and we also want to deepen
our consultation on a more assertive
china
we believe that china must stand up to
defend the multilateral system that it
has benefited from in developing its
country
this summit also shows our leadership in
upholding multilateralism
including through reforms of
multilateral bodies such as the un the
wto and the who
we also discussed ways to boost our
cooperation in security and defense
japan is the only asian partner
specifically mentioned in the strategic
campus a road map for bolstering our
common european security and defense and
we've already have successful joint
naval exercises in the death of adam and
the arabian sea we want to pursue this
further
in the digital domain the launch of our
digital partnership today is a milestone
in fact it's our first digital
partnership with any country it will
help us achieve our shared goals in many
key areas
we are extremely pleased on the
innovation and research front japan has
expressed its interest in being
associated with our horizon europe
program eu and japanese students and
scholars will benefit from this greater
cooperation
sharing knowledge knowhow expertise
highlights our excellent like-minded
cooperation
we are also bending together to protect
our planet and speed up the transition
to climate neutrality
last year we launched our ambitious eu
japan green alliance and now we are
focused on implementation
we also discuss concrete ways to get the
most out of our connectivity partnership
in energy digital transport and
people-to-people connections
the eu and japan have a powerful trade
relationship
the eu and japan the second partnership
is one of the eu trade deals and now we
want to maximize the untapped potential
of this agreement from animal health and
food security to energy cooperation or
geographical indications
dear prime minister di fumio tomorrow i
will be in hiroshima prime minister
defides tom howen
in these challenging times symbols
matter
and we will pay tribute to the victims
of the atomic bomb
the prime minister has long been a
strong voice for a nuclear-free world
and i want to clearly reaffirm that our
actions in times of conflict
must forever be guided by the tragic
history of hiroshima
in light of the war in ukraine this will
be an important moment
to send a powerful message of peace and
of hope i thank you
thank you very much
and may i now invite dr van der lions
prime minister kishida di fumio
we had a very substantive summit um but
first let me express
how glad i am to be here in tokyo
because i know that the european union
in this increasingly unpredictable world
can count on one of its oldest and
closest allies
and likewise because it gives me the
opportunity
of emphasizing once again
that japan can count on the european
union
we showed this not least by ensuring the
delivery of over 390 million doses of
vaccines to fight the covet pandemic and
this gives me the opportunity
to commend you to the outstanding
success of your vaccination campaign
and the way you overcome the
difficulties of the pandemic we all have
experienced
the european union and japan have so
much in common
our values of course
democracy and the rule of law
our economic model
as well as a certain vision of the world
we both promote a multilateral global
system based on rules
designed to protect and benefit all
and it is precisely because this vision
is so often challenged today
that the european union is looking to
strengthen its relationship with
like-minded partners such as japan
quite remarkably today marks the 28th eu
japan summit
a testament of the depth of the bond
between us
at this summit we discussed ways to
deepen our partnership
with concrete strands of work
that will create opportunities for our
economies and our citizens
and that will at the same time help to
us to address the challenges
that our regions are confronted to
and let me elaborate on that
the indo-pacific is a thriving region
it is also a theater of tensions
take the situation in the east and south
china sea or the constant threat of the
dprk
as we discussed prime minister kishida
de fumio the european union wants to
take a more active role in the
indo-pacific we want to take more
responsibility in a region
that is so vital to our prosperity
and this brings me to russia it is today
the most direct threat to the world
order
with a barbaric war against ukraine
and it's worrying packed with china and
their call for new
and very much arbitrary international
relations
japan is part of the core group of
countries that have imposed tough
sanctions
on russia
like the european union japan
understands what is at stake here not
just ukraine's future not just europe's
future
but the future of a rules-based world
order
and this makes it all the more essential
for like-minded partners like the
european union and japan to strengthen
their relations
and this is why we are here today
and we have taken some important steps
forward
first we are launching today
the eu japan digital partnership
it is the first partnership
of this kind
that we conclude with any partner
a forum that will give political steer
and impetus for our joint work on
digital technologies
because leadership in this field is
essential to our competitiveness and our
security
second
we will use our strategic partnership
agreement to diversify and strengthen
our supply chains
this is important because there are
materials and technologies
that have become essential to our
economy and everyday lives like
semiconductors for example
we must be able to count on trustworthy
supply chains
third we agreed to cooperate more
intensively on
infrastructure in the indo-pacific
region as elsewhere
the needs for investment are huge
and the options
the options are limited
they very often come at a price that no
country should have to play like to pay
like encroachments on the sovereignty
for example
and this is why the european union
launched global gateway
and as we discussed prime minister di
fumio we would like to work with japan
on and identifying good projects in this
context
building on our two pioneering
initiatives
the one is the connectivity partnership
and the other one is our green alliance
let me finish prime minister de fumio by
thanking you warmly
for the admirable solidarity that japan
showed
by diverting some of its lng supplies to
europe
it was at a crucial time for us
at the height of the european heating
season
and we will not forget this
this shows the power and the solidarity
of democracies working together thank
you
thank you very much
this concludes the joint press
announcements
thank you very much i thank the leaders
as well as the participants
i would like to ask the member of the
media to stay where you are
until president michelle as well as
president fondo lyon and the prime
minister
kishida have left the hall
oh